I don't think that a lot of men realize
how scary just they are hi my name is de
I'm from New Jersey originally and I'm a
publicist here in LA
hi guys I'm Brett and I work in film I'm
Gabby and I work in film as well
hey act hi everyone I'm kori a I'm from
Los Angeles and I'm an advertising and
recruiting
my name is Farhad I'm born and raised in
LA and I'm a writer nerd director my
name is Joe 25 years old and a marketing
coordinator here in LA
not to say that this is like a sound
fact or that you know there aren't
exceptions but I think you know men are
there they're built differently there's
they're stronger usually I can say yeah
physically is a one inherent difference
obviously it changes based on like their
race in general like the like where
they're from and stuff like that but I
think that women tend to sometimes be a
lot more over emotional and where men
tend to kind of respond a little bit
more stolidly and that might not be the
most like perfect way to say it but I
think of it do you think that's a
natural way that we are were born to be
or do you think that's how we're brought
up I think it's a mixture of both like
this might just be how society has
ingraining and they should react to
certain things - yeah men are supposed
to be this like sometimes uncompromising
unemotional person whereas women are
supposed to be volscian honest I think
that people sometimes like fall into
those categories even when they're not
supposed to be I feel like you know even
as a man like you know how I approach a
problem is like oh how can I fix this
thing whereas like a lot of my female
friends are like like I don't need to
fix it I just need to listen to this
person and and like for me like that's
just not my natural impulse yeah I think
there's so many men who people will say
oh yeah men are always strong or oh is
this always that well tell that to a
female UFC fighters would kick their ass
oh you know I'm saying and they're also
people who will say oh women are always
hyper emotional then thought to a
bleeding-heart guy who is just like the
biggest most passionate person I mean so
I just think generalization is always
problematic my husband is he's one of
those guys that cries in like every
movie you know and like I love that and
I'm like a very assertive fiery person
which is like generally attributed to
masculine quality which in itself is
problematic that we think like strength
is masculine problem-solving is
masculine
we're
all capable and we're all also have our
weaknesses
definitely I've experienced a lot of
disadvantages particularly in the
workforce in my position I'm pretty high
up I kind of sit on the right you know
right hand of the president but it's
just kind of interesting how I'm always
left with all these like administrative
tasks you know I mean and I'm level what
about him and him and him and him and
him but it's just I think it's natural
for people to associate administrative
work with a you know it's a feminine
role saying I work at a hardware store
and which is I get looked over all the
time because I'm like hi how can I help
you and there go I'm gonna ask this guy
like literally just or do not even talk
to me they'll just walk right past me
and go ask a man to touch on more like
disadvantages like just having to think
I think to be more conscious of a lot of
things like people say like walking to
your car at night or going for a jog or
just anything at night really I'm
thinking about it I was like well what
is a disadvantage of being a man and I
thought back to when I was six seven
eight and I was in the school yard and
in the classroom and my friend started
to police me cuz the girls weren't
getting policed from what I understand
the way that the boys were because the
boys were being told don't be like a
girl don't cry don't share your emotions
don't show your feelings because I
wanted to fit in
I embodied those ideas when I was
considering this question you know
derive disadvantages based on my gender
impulses just know like as as a white
man who've raised in you know
middle-class America like right off the
bat you have so many like lack of
barriers I should say you have you have
a lack of barriers for opportunity
well I just would like to let everyone
know that I do not open my own doors
[Laughter]
[Applause]
though seriously though if I'm walking
to if I'm with a male if I'm walking to
the door I won't touch the door um
however if I do open the door if I'm by
myself and there's people behind me I'm
keeping it open whole family females
males no problem at all
but if I am with a male I will not open
the door yeah I look real stupid too
because they usually stand there like as
a joke I'm like where does that
expectation come from oh I'm sure it was
just the way I was raised for me as a
guy like my instinct is like you know
how my dad taught me my brothers is just
like you know treat women with the
utmost respect and honor
I feel like chivalry is just something
that I'm like this is absolutely
something on a step into and to continue
and uphold I think that's like a really
beautiful way to put it I also think
it's not true like that's not born out
of like served because she's up here
it's because we don't it's it's the
opposite of empowerment the same reason
why a guy doesn't think that you can you
know what screw that is is the same
reason why they think they have to open
the door or why it hurts
why chivalry can hurt because the the
idea that like we have to protect and we
have to like do things for them it
translates I it's equal to the idea that
because they are unable to
[Music]
generally speaking I always feel pretty
comfortable when I'm with the opposite
gender I'm the youngest and I have three
brothers and I have a lot of male
figures in my life so I think that that
may influence my feelings on that I grew
up in a family full of women literally
mom had like three sisters like all of
them had pretty much girls and so I was
about 13 so 100% feel like I'm
comfortable with women being around me
I'm a gay black man so literally the
community just forgave black people or
just with gay people in general you
always had like your best girlfriend
that's gonna be there on your side
regardless of whether you just met them
or whether you've known them for 25
years I don't think that a lot of men
realize how scary just they are and how
many men just hang out like feel like oh
that girl could literally kill me like
that's a true thing come from a family
that's like has really strong female
personalities you don't doubt that
anything that they can do because they
were the defenders of the family they
were the ones that raised everybody they
were the strongest people on the family
so I don't I don't know I understand
your yeah I mean I in high school like I
was on the wrestling team I was one of
three girls on their all-boy wrestling
team and I was like yeah this is awesome
like I'm one of the guys it's cool and
you know one of the guys like held a
knife to my throat like behind the
bleachers a game and you know you you
want to be able to to trust and feel
like okay I don't know you so I'm gonna
you know give me give you my trust for a
little bit and then all of a sudden
you're on top of me when do I choose
you're like who do I choose and so it's
like I've never had that with a woman so
I don't think I've always been
comfortable and I am a very private
person and so I'm very intentional about
the relationships that I build and about
the people who I am vulnerable to I
wasn't always comfortable sharing
emotions I heard from childhood to you
know my mid 20s or so I think it was
more of just like this like I mean
bottle it up I'll share with a few
people but it wasn't something I would
share freely and I think now where I'm
at is I see true power and
vulnerabilities share and not fear you
know judgment or shame when I am strong
in the way that I talk and just being
strong people are like oh you're angry
you're you know you don't make sense I'm
like no I make a lot of sense right now
you know just the fact that I have an
emotion makes me unreliable in some way
in people's eyes like we can't have a
woman running the country what if she's
on her period we'll go to war well I
haven't seen it yet I am only
uncomfortable in how I am perceived
because I do want to be perceived as a
competent person and somebody to be
trusted I have taught myself to become
emotional but from my family and from
being a black person in America I don't
think that I am comfortable being
emotional I feel like it's like me
losing control it's me being vulnerable
and I don't like being vulnerable to
anybody unless I choose to and I think
that that's it's a sad thing because
like I should be able to cry whenever I
feel like it but I don't or if I do
cries like I lost the family member last
year and broke into tears and work as
soon as I realized that I was crying I
stopped and I said I have to go home I
apologize I'm leaving right now
and that's that's just how I had to
respond to it and I don't think that's
healthy but it's something that I about
that's just my personal experience when
it comes to being a male a black male in
a mayor
[Music]
yeah I'm thinking it kind of goes back
to just woman being the most like
approachable people that I can come to
and talk about anything when it comes to
me or just my experiences like the
things that have to go through there are
a lot more understanding and I just feel
safe my experience again with the
opposite sexes it's been Pleasant you
know my entire life I've always felt
comfortable I've always felt understood
I've always felt like I had a voice you
know even if it's not again the voice in
the conference room I always felt like
I've always been respected I think like
as a general swathe like take looking at
it that way no men don't understand
women and it's because we're looking at
it as two different things like even the
idea of being assertive comes off as
being a [ __ ] are you speaking from a
personal place or societal place because
I feel like you're you speak from a very
like big place instead of so it's all
the same because the question was I I
not like Society yeah do I feel
understood by men yeah no because they
don't view me as an equal can I see
question in this space do you feel
understood
I feel understood equally by all parties
great not but but you know like I you
know I believe that we're all image
bearers you know image bearers of God
and like that were equal and we're given
these different roles to fulfill and
then when you see uh two people dancing
and it's a beautiful choreographed equal
dance no one's out showing the other
person but when it comes to like
relationships with men and women like I
feel like these different roles can be
such a beautiful thing when done right
but can also be a disaster if one person
is you know trying to outperform or
other person is taking advantage
or overstepping like you said there's
such a beauty in differences and in
masculinity and femininity and it's
important to have both in yourself
[Music]